- All right everybody.
We've reached the end of
the hour, but before we go
I have something awesome
from the internet.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
Here on the show we've been celebrating
Hispanic Heritage Month
which runs from September
15th to October 15th.
Two years ago
Congress passed legislation
calling on the Smithsonian
in Washington DC to
establish the National Museum
of the American Latino.
The new facility should break ground
in a few years, but until then
the museum is hosting exhibits
on American Latino culture.
Here to talk about it is Jorge Zamanillo.
The newly appointed director
of the National Museum
of the American Latino.
Hi Jorge.
(applause)
Hello.
So this is so cool.
So tell us about the gallery.
- You know, we're excited
for this opportunity.
As you mentioned
we premiered our Molina
family Latino Gallery
at the National Museum,
American History back in June.
And this first exhibition
on display, really it's,
it's called Presente and it provides
our foundational story.
It includes historical highlights
cultural legacies of US Latinos
and how Latinos shape American history.
- I love that.
So when will the museum
actually be open to the public?
- Well, you know, this is a 10
or 12 year project, but
we're moving forward.
We're currently reviewing foresight all
along the National Mall
for the location of this
museum, and we're excited.
You know, my goal is to
make sure we build a world
class innovative museum
that will provide us
the opportunity to share all
of our stories and celebrate our culture.
- Absolutely. Don't rush it.
Yeah. Make it right.
That's, that's amazing.
Well, thank you so much, Jorge.
I'm liking your post.
I can't wait to go there one day
and that's not all our season long
Partner Pilot Pen makers of frixion the
to go to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show
values the work that you're doing
and what this means for our country.
So they are gonna make a donation
of $1,000 to the National
Museum of the American Latino.
- Thank you so much.
- Absolutely, Jorge.
Have a good one.
Thank you to all our guests today
Topher Grace, Kelsea Ballerini,
Chloe, and Charlotte.
Y'all have a great day.
If it's not change it.